il la retape est depuis treize ans avec
amour et patience dimanche matin si le
feu lui a laissé l'essentiel sa vie et
celle des siens
il lui a pris tout le reste ouais ouais
ouais je venais juste de finir de poser
la dernière l'âme de plancher la voûte
en pierre on l'a fait avec mon père le
toit on l'a fait avec mon beau frère mes
amis le carrelage l'a fait avec le beau
faire le plancher chauffant la dalle
tout souffre on a étouffé
ils ont évité la catastrophe de peu
parce que dix minutes près ça aurait été
fatale quand je suis sorti
gaël donc la propriétaire a admis sa
voiture et que les enfants les enfants
aient été en semi pas ils sont sortis
pieds nus donc les ai récupérées à la
maison le thouars les doudous les
cadeaux de noël tout est parti en fumée
un crève coeur pour les proches et les
voisins qui ont aussitôt réagi
bien sûr la mairie à reloger mais il
fallait faire plus pour assurer un
quotidien bouleversé des points de
collecte sont spontanément mise en place
à l'école et chez les particuliers pour
tout objet espèces les bonnes volontés
n'ont pas eu besoin d'attestation pour
se manifester
plein de gens ont déposé des sacs cabas
des rempli dhabi devait sceller ces
c'est vraiment vraiment très très
touchant c
c'est comme si eux
la douleur d'avoir perdu le
la maison s'estomper grâce à vraiment
cet élan de de dons et de cadeau que je
suis toujours nous fait c'est vraiment
incroyable
une grande surface a également proposé
d'ouvrir gratuitement une partie de sa
réserve enfin une cagnotte officielle
devrait bientôt voir le jour pour que
noël n'oublie personne